The design of this Little Trees car freshener goes way back to 1952 in Watertown, New York.
And an unhappy milkman who was complaining to one of his customers
about the bad smell of spoiled milk.
Lucky for him, he was talking to Julius Samann, a Jewish chemist who’d fled from Nazi Germany
and spent time living in the forests of Canada
studying the aroma of alpine trees.
After his chance encounter with the milkman, Samann started to create
paper soaked in natural pine oil.
A string was also attached to stop people
getting the perfume all over their hands.
The freshener was originally in the shape
of a buxom pin up girl, but Samann changed
his design to the pine tree we know today.
This allowed the cellophane wrapper to be
rolled down slowly, so the fragrance would
last that little bit longer.
As the automotive industry took off so
did Little Trees.
Filling the air with classics like Black Ice,
Royal Pine, Vanillaroma
and of course New Car Scent.
Fragrant and affordable, this is the design
that brings you
the heady aroma of a Canadian woodland.
Whether you’re in a milk cart or a taxi
cab.